so I'll make them how're you guys doing
we're gonna take a break and I wanna
really people know I've been talking
about milk real milk verse pasteurized
milk and I have nutrition is going on
almost 40 years who's Jim Marlow very
conversant in this area how you doing
mr. Jim I'm doing very well Eddie good
to see it again real milk yes real milk
you know the real milk from healthy
animals you know according to ours
amazed according to the FDA the number
one allergenic food is milk how can this
be mm-hmm we're not talking about real
milk though this has to be that no no
it's interesting that you you bring that
up you know when I was at dr. Mercola is
Clinic beginning in 2002 I worked it
walked into dr. McCullough's office one
day and I said you know Joe I I just
made a connection for some raw dairy
products from some healthy animals I've
been consuming it myself and it feels
absolutely wonderful for me and he
wanted to try some for himself and
everybody who worked at the optimal
wellness center at that time including
all the people on my nutrition team they
all wanted to try to we all tried it
ourselves we all enjoyed it we all felt
good with it even though a number of us
had problems with pasteurized dairy
products we had no problems at all with
raw dairy products from healthy animals
so dr. Cooper Cola supported that we
start promoting raw dairy products from
healthy animals to our patients and it
was a wonderful new dimension of
nutrition that we were that we were
including in our recommendations to our
patients dairy is not right for
everybody even raw dairy from healthy
animals is not a food that that is going
to be right or helps promoting for
everybody but I would say about 90% of
the people that we had worked with who
had had some type of problem with
pasteurized dairy they were either
lactose intolerant with pasteurized
dairy or they had allergies to
pasteurized very when someone has a food
allergy it's because their body's immune
system is is responding to the milk to
the the protein
in the food he about 90% of our patients
who had some type of problem with
pasteurized dairy they had no problem at
all with raw dairy they were able to
digest it it felt good to them it was a
nourishing food for them
there were about 10% of people who had
problems with pasteurized dairy and they
also had some problems with the raw
dairy it wasn't right for everybody but
once we we had resources of raw dairy to
refer our patients to it helped us in
the work we were doing and teaching
people how to use food like their
medicine to strengthen themselves where
they were weak to balance themselves
where they were out of balance and it
was it was a very valuable resource of
health building nutrition for many of
our patients so the reason the FDA would
have milk as the number one allergenic
food because the pasteurized homogenized
a food and your body's having a negative
reaction well what is that right when
yes yes pasteurized dairy can be much
more difficult for the body to properly
digest when you pasteurized area the
first thing you destroys all the natural
enzyme activity in the milk so you know
milk has has lactose which is the milk
sugar but it also in a raw state has
active lactase enzyme lactase enzyme is
the enzyme your body can use to digest
the lactose but when you pasteurize that
is equate pasteurization in this case
with heat damaging when you heat damage
the milk you you totally destroy the
activity of the lactase enzyme so now
you're there's nothing in the milk to
support your digestion of the lactose
also when you pasteurize the milk you
kill all the other enzymes that are in
the milk you know that the the lipases
which are fat digesting enzymes and the
proteases which are protein digesting
enzymes so there's no more ents active
enzyme activity in the mel caster it's
pasteurized so now your body has to do
all the digestive work on its own
because there's no enzymes that that are
left there work there are active enzymes
in raw milk but there's none in they
pasteurized heat damaged milk so also
another thing that you do
when you pasteurize the milk is yes you
do kill all of the the native flora of
from the bacteria that's in the the milk
in a raw state when it's from healthy
animals yes there is bacteria in the
milk but you know there's bacteria
everywhere there's bacteria in us
there's bacteria on us there's bacteria
on the surface of all raw foods raw
plant foods as well as raw animal foods
but when the milk is from healthy
animals the bacteria that's in the mouth
the native flora friendly bacteria
that's in the mouth is very similar to
the same type of bacteria that that are
used to make yogurt and kefir those
those bacterial cultures that are used
to make to turn milk into yogurt used to
turn milk into kefir that's naturally
found in the milk to a very significant
extent a native flora of friendly
bacteria that is in there that can be
very good for our intestinal health and
that's also wiped out by pasteurization
so why was pasteurization originally
done well pasteurization was originally
done because because of industrial asia
industrialization of the dairy industry
and as they had more and more cows on
the dairy farm not allowed to live the
the ideal healthy life for a cow out
open out grazing on an open range
grazing on grass out in the sunshine and
the fresh air when when when the the the
the dairy industry when when their their
individual locations got bigger and
bigger and bigger the animals health was
suffering and so the quality of the milk
was was reduced and so what
pasteurization really did was like when
Louie Pasteur first introduced
pasteurization to the world he basically
introduced it to two winemakers in in
France I think it was in the 1870s he
showed he showed the winemakers how they
could
still profit from a bad crop of grapes
bad crop of grapes that were used to
make wine then then the wine would
ferment over ferment and turn into
vinegar and he showed them that well if
you make the wine and then you heat it
that stops further fermentation and so
the truth about what Louie Pasteur
developed was he showed how you could
actually still produce poor quality wine
but make it acceptable and and this of
course the wine makers were all for this
so he basically showed an industry how
they could profit from a poor quality
product keep it from going bad the same
thing can be said of the dairy industry
early in the 20th century when the
quality of the milk was declining
when pasteurization was introduced
basically that was a method that was
used that was in the early 20th century
but when pasteurization was introduced
it was basically the dairy industry was
basically doing the same thing they were
using a method to make poor quality milk
keeping it from going bad and basically
still profiting from from poor quality
milk from less than truly healthy
animals when you pasteurize it you know
that that would wipe out any of the less
than friendly bacteria that was in the
milk because the animals were were truly
not healthy because of the the
increasingly crowded conditions that
they were living in and of course you
know what what any animal is eating
including human beings it's only a
matter of time before what we are eating
is going to affect our health the
quality of what we're eating is going to
affect our quality one more point before
we cut out on this episode of taking a
break with Jim Marlo we're talking about
pasteurized milk which you find in the
storage homogenized the first real milk
the way the Creator intended for us to
drink people feel like I was I was
skeptical in the beginning I was like
worried is stuff gonna make me sick is
there anything to fear now someone says
if you don't pasteurize it here you can
really get sick pop potentially what do
you say about well raw dairy products
are legally sold at the retail level in
ten states in the United States
California Connecticut South Carolina
seven other states you can find out all
the other states and the the status of
raw dairy products and in your state by
going to real milk calm real milk calm
and so if raw dairy products were truly
potentially dangerous I mean why are
they legal in ten states and in these
ten states where where consumers are
allowed to choose for themselves whether
they want to buy raw dairy products that
typically come from much healthier
animals than the pasteurizer dairy
products that usually come from less
than truly healthy animals you know
people are allowed to choose the raw
dairy products or the pasteurized
heat-damaged dairy products but in in in
Illinois where we live we're not allowed
to make that choice and and that has
nothing to do with public health
although that's the propaganda about it
that's that's you know that's an example
of the the the influence that the
pasteurized dairy industry has had on
our legislature and and the lawmakers
who basically developed these
regulations and and you know if you were
if you were working in the pasteurized
dairy industry wouldn't you want to get
rid of your competition you know so that
you could sell more of your product and
and and and and and make more profit
well that's what has happened in many
states around the country is the
pasteurize that lobbying efforts of the
pasteurized dairy industry have have
they've they've gotten lawmakers and
states to enact legislation or
regulations that make basically make it
either
at the very least difficult or make it
illegal for raw dairy products to be
sold in the at the retail level in
competition with the pasteurized dairy
products but if but again if raw dairy
products were were inherently dangerous
why would they be sold in ten states and
in these ten states where raw dairy is
is is legal people are not getting sick
from consuming raw dairy there's no
there's no problems you know it's just
it's just that the propaganda you know
the propaganda based on ignorance and a
very biased opinion about against raw
dairy products that the propaganda is
that Oh dairy products are potentially
dangerous and and it's it's it's it's
silly to want to seek this out you know
people who say that they don't know what
they're talking about you know rod are
raw dairy products from healthy animals
can be a very valuable health building
food for many people again not everybody
there's there's there's no food that is
universally beneficial to everybody
other than you know breast milk from a
healthy well nourished mother but again
that's that's even an individual
experience but you know it's possible to
have an allergy and intolerance or a
sensitivity to any given food and I
think the reason that the FDA ulis dairy
is the number one most common food
allergy if they do that it's because I
think mostly it's been changed it's
because of the quality of the dairy that
most people are consuming it's managed
it's been made to can we put it in the
classification of fake food now yes yes
yeah I four there are some there are
some organic dairy products that do have
nutritional value for people some
organic yogurts Kieffer's butter or
cottage cheese some other dairy some
certain cheeses that I've seen have
value for people
but as far as you know the kind of the
conventional mainstream non-organic
milks and yogurts and Kieffer's or
cheeses and all that type of stuff
I see those foods as often being
problems trouble making foods for people
rather than health supporting foods so
you know food food quality is a
fundamental issue that we really need to
be persistently faithful to be attentive
to and then faithful to buying seeking
out and buying the best quality food
that God nature have to offer us there
you have it difference between
pasteurized homogenized FDA has put it
as one of the leading allergenic foods
your body's having a negative reaction
to it but that's the fake food not the
real food it's benefited me hopefully
I'll benefit you Jim gives it a thumbs
up for the real food real milk and they
can get healthy humanely raised animals
healthy I strongly recommend that you
seek out some raw dairy from a farmer in
your area or from a raw dairy based food
co-op in your area or if you're in
California Connecticut South Carolina or
one of the other states where raw dairy
is legal
I think raw dairy is more likely to be
supportive of good health for you than
pasteurized heat damaged and homogeneous
dairy products this is the way the
Creator has intended for us for all of
humanity we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you subscribe if you
haven't already